hiking camping and exploring the woods  is a favorite pastime for many children  and adults but you are in for a big  surprise if you happen to stumble upon  this particular expanse of woods  designated by the foundation as scp-4000  it's an extra dimensional area occupied  by the fey a powerful race of reality  warpers believed to have been at war  with the foundation after the infamous  factory incident the woods are their  domain but the foundation operatives  must take a path through it once every  year however they must abide by certain  rules while inside like never using or  answering to names your own or any  others while inside  scp-4000 as it gives the mystical  entities great power over you dr japers  made the mistake of not taking this  seriously after speaking with a rabbit  man and responding to the name fellow  scholar twice in a row he was owned by  the fae he disappeared only to be  replaced by a humble non-anomalous  rabbit